I sympathize with the difficulties that  they  they have in all the regulations they  want to change I accept that but I don't  think they should inconvenience people  that really need to get to places it  just affects all our lives isn't it and  we well in my case I just have to change  my trips and so on to match the days and  I just wish we'd managed to organize  ourselves rather better yeah  um you know Railways are absolute vital  service and I just can't understand why  we don't run them on a national basis  they can't walk because like if there's  a Twist right  I have to catch the boss which is like  eight hours from Worcester down here